hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on for honor it again
and real quick as this video goes live I
should be going and I should be on
stream we're gonna be playing some PC
gameplay with a couple friends but I
needed to hop on xbox because this is
the only account that I have a rep 70
character within specific rep 70
gladiator and as you may or may not have
known they've actually added the rep 70
rewards because I believe last season we
got rep 70 by complete accident but now
they officially added rep 70 rewards so
this is the only reward we're gonna get
is called probably 17 it looks like this
honestly not too bad not too bad at all
it's it's a lot longer than I thought it
would be and I'll totally keep it pop it
to the Y button first here but maybe
there's email potential I doubt it but
real quick we're just gonna be going
into some op you know doing some quick
like a quic Dominion game showing it off
nothing too crazy and ya see when the
game has started a load of sakura's of
course it is I feel like one of those
[ __ ] that's like yeah when a new
character comes out to prey on all the
news I'm gonna go use my main I feel
like one of those guys right now I hate
when people do that
but I gotta do it for the video see the
one thing we gotta check though is how
does it look in game so we got yeah I
got the little red to it I should
probably I think what would fit really
well with this is maybe the Reta
the rep 60 with the gold I think the
gold would look really clean with that
see if there's a mode spin not really
that kind of sucks cuz it's really just
like you walking up so there really is
it gonna be much emote spam potential
which is kind of sad still got it
okay stunting on kids right now I got to
get a little bit used to it I think yeah
but I really do think that the rep 60
would pair well with the 70 just because
of that gold coloring I think that would
be I think that's gonna be the move
fighting a soccer run ow
oh yeah I forgot they changed all the UI
so it's all on the left and not at the
very top which is really nice I think it
looks really clean that way they changed
a lot for this season in terms of UI and
HUD stuff and I think it just looks a
lot better a lot more professional
and especially the stuff in the top I
think the the top right is probably my
favorite the way they did the Dominion
stuff me see if I can move on to here go
through see I think that's a Sakura it's
got to be yeah a couple Sakura's fight
and I got to ruin the fight as usual god
I'm really portraying this like scumbag
guy does this match that's gonna hurt oh
yeah she has the uninterruptible thing I
can't do anything
all right if I get a deflect honor
okay oh I missed okay
good Perry oh I got double-teamed all
right
soccer is a little quick not to not too
quick but that zone came out a little
bit quicker than I thought this is the
even like our early access this is
actually the first time I have fought a
Sakura
all right hito kiri like in game because
during the early access all we could
really do is play AI matches or queue up
with others and I didn't know anybody's
names cuz we all had different names for
the account so I couldn't really do with
anybody so this is the first time
actually fighting her I got to play with
her I played with her a lot
knowing the moves and how to use them
and stuff but in terms of like playing
against one not at all
seems like her guard break range isn't
as big so I might be interesting oh my
[ __ ] lord brother we're getting
cooked up been checked out my recent
video they actually removed the tomb so
the back area here is actually a lot
smaller they moved the tomb to the back
because this place used to be accessible
so now it's gone to make this a little
bit more even which I like and then I'm
over there somewhere they added the
slope to the ladder they just make it
easier to get to when you're going s but
it was really effective and it really
took a toll during a competitive like
tournament play other than that it
wasn't too big of an issue and regular
matchmaking that's gonna hurt a lot toe
stab is still brutal as for if gladiator
can keep up with Sakura I think he
totally can
she has a lot of moves a few unblockable
some kicks some soften you know stuff
like you know all the good stuff that a
character should have but I think he can
keep it up against them baited I think
he'll do just fine she does a lot of
damage but so does Highlander so
but she just has a lot more capability I
think Gladiators gonna be fine against
her it's really just characters that
have fast attacks that you know like
beserker mostly assassins are what
really [ __ ] him over because of his
very bad guard the change is always bad
and especially characters were really
long moves that's the only issue I I
think Sakura I thought I can already
tell
Sakura's moves a couple of them are
gonna be a little bit longer than his
guard stance
I believe his her heavy unblockable is
definitely gonna be there and then maybe
her maybe her just her standard heavy
I'm not sure but some of these moves
like a little bit slow for him to
because I can't do it on reaction that
was a quick one that's a light that's a
that's a heavy not a light okay I also
got to get used to which is a light
which is a heavy nice parry
yeah that one's definitely slower than
my guard that's gonna hurt
oh she ate that oh okay that shows up on
the left oh my god the skulls on the
right now that's beautiful so what
happened so is that when is that every
time yes okay awesome all right so the
skull does show up on the right now
which is great I don't know if you've if
any of you guys are new to the game or
haven't really paid attention every time
a person dies it shows up on the middle
of the screen right where your guard
stances so it really affects your your
match that like especially if you're in
a fight it really affects it because you
never know what happened what could
happen like someone could throw a move
and because that big skull being in the
middle you can't see it so now that it's
on the right it's completely avoided and
I actually think that's really sick I'm
very glad that that's a thing yeah boys
that was the rep 70 emo just wanted to
show it off a little bit see what it is
in game the kind of see what it is from
the hero menu let me know if you guys
think it's worth it I really don't think
it's that great of a emo I still think
the rep 70 room or the rep 60 reward is
a lot better than 70 that's just the
personal thing to me but honestly yeah I
mean if you if you have a rep 70
character there's no reason why you
shouldn't grab this and if you have like
a 60 and you're really close to 70 I
mean you're right there you might as
well just grab it anyway just in case
cuz you never know you might actually
end up using it I'll show it again one
more time just so that everyone can see
it
if they didn't get a chance to it should
be right here this is the proudly 70 emo
pretty good pretty good it's a pretty
long one too I'm I was actually really
impressed I don't remember it being this
long I may have just clicked it off when
I was looking at it earlier that's not
bad if we go to the effects if we can
change free-roam emo to rep 60 if we do
it to that one what if we do what if we
change it now okay yeah what if we get
to the 60 and it's like all by Yello
yeah I think this one is a lot better I
think having the rep 60 sulfuric sparks
really flows well with this not bad not
bad
let me know what you guys think down in
the comments below like to be if you do
enjoy guys subscribe if you're new I
covered the informational side a
foreigner that being the balance changes
the hero updates the patch notes in the
leaks if one be kept up today with
everything happening in the world of
foreigner that was described the channel
I'll be streaming probably after this
video goes live with a couple of friends
of mine youtuber friends that you might
know so yeah don't we check that stream
I'll be here on YouTube so you don't
have to go anywhere like twitch or
anything like that yeah peace out guys
have a girls today and enjoy the new
season
[Music]
you